être bensoussan bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france à
leurs stock sera fixé sur son sort donc
aujourd'hui regard de la constitution
américaine donald trump
at il le droit justement de bloquer le
réseau social
lorsque on a des éléments de relatif à
l'espionnage le gouvernement américain
et le président dispose de très larges
pouvoirs on l'a vu notamment dans le
domaine de l'application du verger en
europe oui il dispose d'un très grand
pouvoir pour protéger la nation
américaine
par contre de la même manière le juge et
c est là la liste ats-unis sont une
véritable démocratie à ce niveau là le
juge aussi a beaucoup de pouvoir et il y
a la capacité
dans le cas de l'application de la
constitution et des principes généraux
du droit américain la possibilité de
donner à tik tok éventuellement un répit
alors vous l'avez dit donald trump
accuse depuis des mois l'application
d'espionnage au profit de pékin en
collectant les données de ses
utilisateurs notamment quelles sont les
preuves dont il dispose moi je ne sais
pas je n'ai pas ce n'est pas j'ai pas
capacité à apprécier les preuves dont
dispose l'administration américaine par
contre les données personnelles sont un
enjeu extrêmement important on entre
dans une nouvelle diplomatie comme le
disait aklil diplomatie de la donnée
personnelle et il est évident que
contrôler pouvoir espionner disposer
d'informations sûres données
personnelles des différents sortait sont
des autres pays est un enjeu majeur dans
les cas de cette nouvelle gouvernance de
données et il appartient à tous les
gouvernements de cette canette et demain
il sera nécessaire de mettre en place
une convention internationale
en fait si on veut toujours protéger la
paix il y à des règlements
sion dans la plupart des pays pour la
protection des données personnelles en
europe le fameux règlement général par
protection des personnels mais la sphère
états unis film montre bien que pour la
maîtrise et de mes personnels et une
gouvernance des données de paie il
faudra nécessairement une convention
internationale
on peut pas rester avec des
réglementations locales
que risquent réellement l'application
suite à cette audience
juste une interdiction d'être à
télécharger sur le sol américain
oui c'est chacun des pays acp
possibilité de pouvoir contrôler a
priori la diffusion des applications
dans leur domaine de souveraineté sais
pas si c'est un plein coûte tenu de la
liberté de l'internet mais les états
unis la plupart des pays développés ont
des possibilités de réguler l'internet
on a vu que déjà la chine avait interdit
un certain nombre de réseaux sociaux on
se retrouve de la même manière du côté
des états unis avec une possibilité
technique qui n'est pas quand même si
dassier que ça à faire respecter compte
tenu du caractère sans frontières de
l'internet est ce que l'entreprise
dispose de recours au cas où justement
elle est interdite d'accès aux états
unis oui elle et disposent de leurs
cours mais là encore on est on est face
à ce qu'on appelle un droit d'exception
puisque le droit des cieux nages 2
gouvernement de très larges possibilités
et une régulation du juge plutôt réduite
au titre des principes fondamentaux
je serai là-bas dépend beaucoup des
preuves dont dispose l'administration
pour interdire en temps p même s'il ya
une très grande tension entre les
etats-unis et la chine
une possibilité d'utiliser un réseau
social comme celui tik tok
mais c'est vrai que la gouvernance des
données personnelles c'est pose
aujourd'hui de nouvelles règles du jeu
et que c'est un niveau un nouveau
terrain d'affrontement entre l'ensemble
des démocraties
merci beaucoup en tout cas monsieur ben
soussan à la même façon d'avoir répondu
aux questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste en droit du numérique
et des nouvelles technologies